at least six people have been confirmed
dead after fire at a hostel in New
Zealand the loafers Lodge in Wellington
is used by migrants and vulnerable
people placed there by government
agencies the Prime Minister Chris
Hipkins visited the scene
I think any fire that involves someone
passing away is difficult for our First
Responders but a situation like this is
really difficult we've not seen an event
of the scale for some quite some time so
they'll be really feeling this as well I
know that they have done everything that
they could and I just want to reiterate
our thanks and our gratitude to them for
for what they have endured over the last
few hours and of course our reiterate
again our Sympathy for the victims and
for the people who care about them their
family their whanau and their loved ones
okay let's speak now to Caitlin McGee a
journalist in Auckland Caitlin a pretty
devastating fire tell us more about what
happened
yeah so it's been described as a once in
a decade fire it was a 95 room uh hostel
in most of those rooms were believed to
have been occupied at the time people
were having to crowd on the roof which
was deemed as pretty unstable others had
to flee by jumping out of Windows and
um and some of course obviously got
stuck at the moment special
investigators have been brought in from
around the country to try and figure out
how this fire occurred because at the
moment it's unexplained we know that at
least six people have been killed but
that death toll could be as high as 10.
um it's been really complicated and
difficult for a lot of the firefighters
to try and get into the building to
figure out exactly how many people were
trapped and part of that is because the
roof was figured deemed to be very very
unstable but also there was a real risk
that it might collapse and also there
was an asbestos risk in the building
from some of the building materials that
it was made of
um so aside from the fire it's South and
the time of day that the blaze began
there have been a number of other
factors that have made the entire
operation around it incredibly
complicated and Caitlin do we know much
more about the residents of the building
I believe it was frequently used to
House people who'd been deported from
Australia
so we've had some reports from media
Outlets both in New Zealand and also in
Australia like Sydney Morning Herald uh
saying that some of the people living
there are what's known as 501 deportees
which are uh
essentially New Zealand citizens who
have been living in Australia who may
have committed a crime and been deported
back to New Zealand uh already uh there
are questions that are starting to be
being asked at a political level
um about how vulnerable these people may
have been
and why some of these people may have
been living and what might be considered
to be substandard living conditions at
the moment we've had Green's co-leader
in Parliament today
um sort of asking questions at a
political level level saying you know
what kind of country are we living in
with these people have so few options
um in life but to live in substandard
accommodation
um with such a chance of and being of
lethality and being so at risk so there
is this real sense of discontent
starting to brew about the kinds of
conditions uh that these boarding houses
were potentially operating under there
have been some conflicting reports here
earlier in the day that the sprinklers
inside the building didn't go off when
the alarms did so a really difficult
situation and lots of vulnerable people
from different walks of life living in
that in that building well thank you for
that Caitlin McGee a journalist speaking
to us there from Auckland